[Musica]
[Applauso]
il mondo è un covo di ladri e sta
scendendo la notte il male rompe le sue
catene corre per la terra come un cane
Furioso Il veleno ci ha infettati tutti
Nessuno si salva
un giorno alla nostra scuola di
recitazione arriva una ragazza avrà
avuto circa una trentina d'anni mi
prende da parte e mi dice Federica Io ho
bisogno del tuo aiuto tu mi devi
insegnare a fingere Come fanno gli
attori io in ufficio dei colleghi
stronzi Non ce la faccio più Sono
esasperata ma non posso andarmene per
questo sono qui perché voglio imparare a
dissimulare a
mentire io la guardo non Sap sapevo cosa
dirle le uniche parole che mi sono
uscite spontanee sono state Mi dispiace
ma io non credo che tu sia nel posto
giusto il teatro è un viaggio verso la
verità Allora lei mi ha guardata con
delusione e mi ha detto Eh sei così non
mi interessa e se n'è
andata io so che può sembrare strano ma
è grazie al teatro che ho imparato ad
essere umana ad essere me
stessa facendo teatro ho imparato a
conoscere meglio la vita a esprimere
quello che sento ad accettare il
cambiamento e un mondo sempre più
diversificato ed è proprio per questa
ragione che oltre a fare l'attrice ho
scelto di insegnare teatro perché il
teatro ci aiuta a liberare la nostra
autenticità ma non lo fa in modo diretto
non arriva lì e ti dice Dai Federica
libera il tuo istinto scatena le tue
emozioni Dai tira fuori quello che hai
dentro se facesse così farebbe una paura
nera non lo farebbe nessuno manco un
pazzo e lui lo sa e ti
frega ti fa lavorare sul
personaggio un'altra vita un'altra
storia non sei
tu Sì ma per mettere in scena quel
personaggio tu devi mettere a
disposizione tutto il tuo corpo tutta
tutta la tua voce devi scavare dentro di
te Per trovare quelle emozioni quei
sentimenti che possano rendere il tuo
personaggio vero
credibile ricordo quando stavo lavorando
al monologo della moglie ebrea di Brecht
il regista a un certo punto mi chiede di
fare questa cosa di rivolgermi verso il
muro di immaginare che lì ci sia mio
marito dal quale mi dovrò presto
separare e di dirgli la battuta come se
stessi chiedendogli
aiuto
Ok Mi rivolgo verso il
muro
Immagino che lì ci sia mio marito e dico
la battuta dal buio la sua voce eh
Quello non è aiuto devi dire la battuta
come se stessi chiedendogli aiuto va
bene rifaccio e quello non è aiuto devi
chiedere aiuto devi chiedere aiuto va
bene rifaccio un'altra volta non va bene
Inizio a cercare quella sensazione
dentro di me lui continua a incalzare io
rifaccio sbaglio a un certo punto
qualcosa dentro prende il sopravvento Mi
rivolgo verso di lui e gli dico Non lo
so fare va bene io non so chiedere aiuto
Non me l'ha insegnato
nessuno scoppia a
piangere in quel momento mi rendo conto
di non saper fare una cosa così così
semplice così
naturale da bambina avrò chiesto aiuto a
qualcuno ai miei genitori Maè per forza
se sono viva ma quella sensazione non
riusciva a trovarla dentro di me
probabilmente perché crescendo mi sono
convinta che nella vita avrei dovuto
sempre farcela da
sola quel momento di verità aveva fatto
scendere in teatro un Silenzio assoluto
i miei compagni mi guardavano chi Con un
sorriso qualcuno con una lacrima a quel
punto il regista mi dice va bene Allora
il tuo compito per questa settimana è di
chiedere aiuto Fatti aiutare dalle
persone impara ti
servirà e così alla veneranda età dei 34
anni Federica ha re imparato a chiedere
aiuto e fatto un passo avanti nella sua
evoluzione tante volte nella vita per
essere accettati per essere apprezzati
dai nostri genitori dai nostri amici
magari dai nostri insegnanti abbiamo
dovuto soffocare i nostri istinti i
nostri sentimenti i nostri bisogni e
queste sensazioni queste emozioni che
poi sono le più oneste le più spontanee
rimangono sepolte in qualche angolo
dentro di noi e ci limitiamo a portare
nel mondo soltanto quelle due o tre
modalità che ci fanno sentire al sicuro
Ma quei sentimenti che chiudiamo in un
cassetto scavano dentro di noi e può
succedere che a un certo punto esplodano
e venga fuori in maniera incontrollata
tutta la rabbia tutta la delusione tutta
la frustrazione tutto l'amore che ci
siamo impediti di o di
dare il teatro mi ha allenata a rimanere
in contatto con le mie emozioni tutte
quelle belle e quelle brutte a
conoscerle ad accettarle a dar loro una
voce a portarle fuori Mi ha insegnato a
dare valore al mio mondo
interiore e poi mi ha allenata
all'empatia
Come si fa a interpretare il personaggio
di un folle assassino come come Annibal
Lecter dura beh Eh allora innanzitutto
Innanzitutto non dovrei giudicare che è
difficilissimo perché noi nella vita
Siamo bravissimi a giudicare è una delle
competenze che alleniamo di più se ha
fatto così è cattivo ce l'ha con me non
valgo niente E tutto questo c'ha lontana
dal nostro personaggio ma poi in realtà
anche dalle persone e da noi stessi
nella vita Ecco il teatro mi ha chiesto
di non giudicare ma anzi di allenarmi a
trovare quelle motivazioni per cui quel
personaggio fa quelle determinate scelte
fino ad arrivare a pensare che io al
posto suo avrei fatto esattamente la
stessa cosa Io non chiedo al ferito come
si sente io divento ferito Questa è
l'empatia
quanto migliorerebbero le nostre
relazioni quotidiane Ma pensate anche le
relazioni nelle aziende nelle
organizzazioni se fossimo allenati a non
giudicare sempre e a metterci nei panni
dell'altro e poi il teatro mi ha
allenata alla
trasformazione che è una cosa difficile
perché in realtà il cambiamento spaventa
sempre tutti anche i più allenati fin da
quando non sono entrati in accademia a
20 anni ero una ragazza molto esteriore
Ero molto preoccupata ad essere sempre
bella sempre truccata sempre precisa
sempre Brava Sempre
apprezzata il teatro mi ha liberata da
questa schiavitù e mi ha dato il
permesso mi ha autorizzata ad essere
tutto ciò che mi va bella brutta giovane
vecchia come quando giocavamo da bambini
prendevi un asciugamano lo giravi
intorno al collo e zac diventavi Batman
Io ho la stel della Senna mi piaceva
Però se l'asciugamano lo giravi lo
mettevi sulle spalle in un secondo
potevi diventare La piccola fiammiferaia
se lo giravi intorno alla testa W facevi
volare il tappeto ecco per me la
bellezza è legata a questa libertà al
poterti trasformare e ne ho avuto Prova
in uno dei momenti più difficili della
mia vita quando ho dovuto curarmi per un
tumore al seno la perdita dei capelli è
uno dei momenti più dolorosi per una
donna in cura Ma anziché guardarmi allo
specchio magari piangere e pensare
quanto sono sfigata Ho chiesto al teatro
di aiutarmi
Io sono un'appassionata dei film della
Marvel antico è un mago potentissimo
maestro supremo delle Arti mistiche
e è una donna ed è
pelata Mi sono
detta lei è un personaggio potentissimo
conosce i segreti dell'universo è
consapevole della propria forza
interiore ha tutto dentro di sé per
questo è così
essenziale E così per un periodo della
mia
vita ho scelto di esplorare
L'essenziale in casa mi sono vestita con
delle tuniche ho sfoggiato Serena la mia
testa pelata e ho cercato di lavorare
dentro di me in connessione con me
stessa a cercare la mia forza interiore
ho preso ispirazione da un
personaggio Ecco grazie al teatro sono
riuscita a vivere con ironia un momento
difficile un momento doloroso e quando
riesci a avere questo atteggiamento con
una delle cose più spaventose che ci sia
la malattia Beh penso
che comunque vada hai giocato una grande
partita tante persone nella mia vita
Quando hanno saputo che faccio l'attrice
mi hanno risposto Wow Beata te Ma allora
tu sai fingere eh perché se sai fingere
secondo loro Eh beh hai la vita spianata
hai una marcia in più non ti esponi mai
nessuno nota mai le tue fragilità le tue
debolezze puoi sempre apparire bello
forte imperturbabile
Cool per me questo è
l'inferno E
allora com'è il
[Musica]
paradiso
immaginate un mondo
nuovo una nuova
era un
mondo dove l'educazione
teatrale fa già parte della nostra vita
di
tutti fin da quando siamo
bambini ti alzi il
mattino
m
Ah ti
prepari e vai al bar a fare
colazione entri il barista
zac ti dà il tuo caffè ti guardi un po'
intorno e può capitare che mentre giri
lo zucchero con il cucchiaino fai un tin
tin sulla tazzina e subito il tuo vicino
ti risponde tin tin e poi si unisce
quello dietro di cui Non te n'eri
neanche accorto con un bel tin tin
Buongiorno e immediatamente tutto il bar
improvvisa una sinfonia meravigliosa
improvvisata tin tin tin tin tin
Buongiorno tin tin la mia brioche tin
tin tin tin e tu esci che hai già il
cuore aperto e dici Ma che bella la vita
come sono contento e pensi che in fin
dei conti quegli estranei sono proprio
come te arrivi al lavoro oggi giornata
di quelle veramente riunioni col capo si
prendono decisioni strategiche per
l'azienda siete lì tutti vestiti bene
intorno al tavolo vi guardate e i primi
10 minuti cosa
fate vi
abbracciate Ciao
Buongiorno Inizia a fare qualche
esercizio di attivazione per per
stimolare l'ascolto e per essere pronto
appunto ad ascoltare l'altro prima di
avere bisogno di dire di dire subito la
tua e tutti si sentono si sentono
accolti si sentono apprezzati e lavorate
insieme per creare qualcosa che abbia un
impatto positivo Cazzo son già le 4 devo
andare a prendere mio figlio a scuola
vai arrivi un po' trafilato lui sale in
macchina lo guardi è vestito come un
Punk metallaro
disagiato ti sale un nervoso che
vorresti dirli Ma come cazzo ti sei
vestito ti sei
visto Ma riesci a fermarti in tempo
perché ti ricordi quanto soffrivi quando
tuo padre alla sua età ti diceva
esattamente le stesse cose ma allora era
un altro mondo l'educazione teatrale non
faceva ancora parte della nostra vita e
allora riesci a stare
zitto respiri non vi dite niente ma quel
silenzio riesci a sentire quanta
fragilità quanta quanto coraggio e anche
quanta bellezza c'è in un momento della
vita in cui hai bisogno di essere
accettato e di trovare te
stesso la giornata scorre veloce arriva
arriva la sera ti prepari per andare a
dormire entri in camera tua moglie dorme
già da un
pezzo ormai i bei momenti in cui
facevate l'amore fino a tardi presi
dalla passione sono un lontano ricordo
ti sale la malinconia Ma guardi
dormire non vuoi ferirla le vuoi
bene però però il teatro ti ha insegnato
che puoi che puoi dire quello quello che
senti quello che provi Va bene allora
domani glielo dico che la desidero
ancora e lei saprà ascoltarmi
e se
litighiamo pazienza a volte è necessario
per ritrovarsi vai a chiudere le
finestre butti un occhio ancora su il
tuo quartiere ci sono ancora qualche
qualche luce accesa pensi Chissà che ci
sarà dall'altra parte di quelle finestre
e ti viene Ti viene di lanciare così
nell'aria un bel
Buonanotte
Buonanotte notte
notte E mentre ti stai per
addormentare lì
tranquillo ti torna in mente quella fase
di
Bergman che
dice il mondo è un covo di ladri e sta
scendendo la notte il male rompe le sue
catene corre per la terra come un cane
Furioso Il veleno ci ha infettati tutti
Nessuno si
salva perciò godiamoci la felicità
mentre siamo felici concediamoci di
essere gentili generosi affezionati e
buoni è necessario e niente affatto
riprovevole provare piacere ed essere
felici Nel nostro piccolo mondo il
teatro
[Applauso]
[Musica]
Grazie